просто зараз до нашого ефіру долучається
наступний гість - це Сергій шкарлет
Міністр освіти і науки України пане
Сергію п міністрів Вітаю вас вітаю вас
Доброго ранку Слава Україні Героям слава
пане міністр скільки школярів в якому
форматі наразі продовжують навчання в
Україні чи змінилися умови і форми
навчання у другому семестрі
перш за все хочу подякувати каналу
журналістам за увагу до питання освіти
адже коли ми говоримо про освіту Ми
говоримо про майбутнє якщо нас цікавить
наше майбутнє то ми як нація непереможні
на сьогодні в цілому освітній процес
відбувається в 12
1926 школах з них
8563 школи працюють очном або змішаному
форматі Тобто це
майже 70% інші школи - це десь
363 школи працюють виключно в онлайн
форматі Це взагалі-то залежить від
безпеки у ситуації від наявності тих
бомбосховищів укриттів які сьогодні
облаштовані в закладах освіти в цілому
ми варто зазначити що 5 областях
освітній процес відбувається виключно в
онлайн форматі це є Донецька Запорізька
Луганська Харківська Херсонська і це теж
є питання безпеки наших дітей Дякую вам
за запитання
прошу будь ласка якщо можна розкажіть
більше про програму забезпечення учнів і
вчителів планшетами і ноутбуками А от я
й як їх розподіляють
Дуже дякую за запитання ну перш за все з
першого з початку 24 лютого з
повномасштабної широкомасштабної агресії
ми як Міністерство освіти Звернулися до
наших світових партнерів це наші колеги
з юнісером з Юнеско з
всевзичівден це наші програми які
пов'язані з
підтримкою освіти на міжнародному рівні
ми на сьогодні більше 70 тисяч цифрових
девайсів вже розвезені по учням і
вчителям на сьогодні покрито близько 54%
потреби і ми зосередились над тим що
сьогодні більшість дітей Ми маємо
забезпечувати сам
освітніми гаджетами Окрім цього є
програми підтримки і підручників є
програми підтримки і автобусів є
програми підтримки створення бомбосховищ
ми на сьогодні тільки нещодавно
вчора вручили в п'ятницю вручили майже
300 планшетів нашої спеціальній установі
школи супергероїв це дітки які
перебувають на тривалому довготривалому
лікуванні навчаються в нас також в
закладах медицини і ми вдячні за
співпрацю з мозом в нас компанії Apple
на сьогодні більше ніж 5000 айпадів для
дітей і вчителів пропонує Ми також по
областях реалізуємо в нас 6000 цифрових
девайсів було роздано в грудні місяці за
сприяння корейського уряду Ми також
роздавали Безумовно в кожного з
донаторів в них свої пріоритети по
розподілу але в цілому це стосується
більше саме деокупованих територій
бойових територій територій на яких
більше за всіх перемістилося внутрішньо
переміщених осіб тому працюємо за радіо
освіти і Дякуємо всім наша любинорам за
нашою західний проект у системно
підтримки освітянських потреб галузі
Дуже дякую
але міністра Скажіть будь ласка як
вплинуло на вашу думку війна на якість
освіти в Україні взагалі чи можна
оцінити це зараз
саме цим питанням Ми якраз і опікуємося
разом з нашим
таким співдружнім закладом це державна
служба якості освіти Ми проводимо за
програмою специфічної програми еволюя
сьогодні оцінюємо освітні розриви і
найближчим часом
ми представимо результати цих досліджень
Я сподіваюсь що саме ваш канал буде
перший євро висвітлювати Дякую вам а
щодо тестування от чи проходитимуть
тестування діти четвертих та 9-х класів
які умови для тих хто навчається онлайн
Дуже дякую Дуже актуальне питання
сьогодні
в минулому п'ятницю Міністерство юстиції
повернуло нам затверджений за юстований
наказ про скасування державної
підсумкової атестації для учнів
четвертих і дев'ятих класів у
2023 році Отже 9 4 і 9-й класи державних
підсумкова атестацію складати не будуть
що стосується 11 класу То ми сьогодні
чекаємо прийняття Верховною
законопроекту
8228-1 який скасовує державну підсумкову
атестацію і запроваджує альтернативу до
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання
формуємо модель вступу на 2023 рік Дякую
за запитання
А що стосується мультимедного тестування
наскільки повноцінне це
повноцінна альтернатива ЗНО
Дякую нагадаю що сьогодні до Верховна
Рада не проголосувала зміни до Закону
України Про вищу освіту сьогодні єдиним
інструментом вступу єдиної моделі вступу
залишається класичне ЗНО Але при цьому
Міністерство освіти і науки ще в
листопаді місяці Минулого року
запропонувало певну альтернативу
враховуючи воєнний стан і безпеку
ситуації і на сьогодні
національний мультиплектний тест його в
тому варіанті в якому розширеному
варіанті які ми запропонували на 23-й
рік він безумовно є моделлю яка
наближена до зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання принаймні вирішує ті питання
прозорого і справедливого вступу для тих
хто має найкращі бали і на сьогодні
процедура проведення
національного мультику предметного тесту
вони абсолютно подібні до зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання і вирішу самі
поставлені завдання для ЗНО які і
вирішуються національним тестом Дякую
вам А якщо говорити про ммт тобто
національний предметний тест
2023 він відрізняється від минулорічного
і чим
Дякую за запитання знову ж таки це
питання на актуальне яке сьогодні турбує
випускників адже ми розраховуємо
приблизно однакову кількість як у
минулому році приблизно 224 тисячі
випускників які планують вступати в 2023
році результати
нмт або модель
нмт-23-2023 Вона майже подібна моделі
nnmt 2022 єдине що це той самий
комп'ютерний тест який учасники
проходять тимчасових ізомінаційних
центрах або в закладах освіти або в
спеціальне обладнаних тестах також сюди
будуть долучатись наші закордонні
партнери принаймні 32 країни які були в
минулому році
50-6 міст з усього світу процедури
проведення
нмт максимально наближення до процедур
проведення 22-го року єдине більше буде
декілька наборів щодо тестування де
вступник або абітурієнт може для себе
обрати одну з 5 представлених моделей
предметів для вступу національного
мультику тесту 23-му році
Ну і ми з вами це питання вже піднімали
А можна я ще раз перепитаю А ви ще раз
відповіс відповісте чи можна буде обрати
історію
а звісно абсолютно вірно ми передбачили
в тому контексті національного
мультиплекмічного тесту на 23-й рік
обов'язково два предмети математика і
українська мова оскільки це є предмети в
принципі підсумкової атестації ДПА і
мають найбільшу прогностичну валідність
а далі вступник буде обирати для себе
іноземну мову історію України безумовно
історію України буде обирати хімію
біологія або фізику в цьому контексті
для всіх буде встановлені певні
рейтингові коефіцієнти по кожному з цих
наборів можна буде вступити на кожну з
спеціальностей по кожному з цих наборів
можна буде обрати будь-який напрям який
вступник хоче навчатися і без обмежень
тому в цьому контексті ми даємо більш
ширшу свободу у виборі вступнику щодо
максимальної демонстрації власних знань
і власної підготовки за під час навіть
воєнного стану
а мінімальний прохідний бал це от
цьогорічне нововведення але він здається
чи не найнижче у світі 10%, А для чого
потрібні це нововведення
Ну ви знаєте це не нововведення адже ми
на регульовані спеціальності взагалі то
ставили 150 і 140 і 130 балів ті
10%, ну якби знаєте я б трошки
переформатував би запитання адже мені
дуже подобається взагалі-то
стратегія деяких університетів деяких
бізнес-шків не тільки в світі а вже
сьогодні в Україні коли все було
придбаєте за вступника за якість
випускника і саме на сьогодні в умовах
прийому є питання Незалежно від того чи
Міністерство встановіть ці 10%, чи не
встановиться 10%. хочу привести приклад
Київської школи економіки Київська школа
економіки надзвичайно цінує свій власний
Імідж вона цінується на ринку праці на
сьогодні в київській школі економіки в
окремих правилах прийому встановлюються
додаткові порогові бали щодо вступу до
Київської школи економіки і саме це
дисциплінує по-перше викладацький склад
і підвищу якість і цінні самого навчання
для жодного університету України
сьогодні не існує порогів щодо
встановлення певного додаткового балу
або або порогову балу щодо вступу в той
чи інший університет точно знаю що деякі
ректори мають наміри користуватися цим
адже ну в певному в певному випадку ці
10% вони навіть нижче пороговгадування
але певним чином це дисциплінує
здобувачів освіти все ж таки більш
глибоко перейматися якістю навчання
глибиною отриманих знань Дякую за
запитання
хочеться поставити з огляду на нашу
ситуацію таке питання чи всі заклади
освіти на тепер вже мають захисні
споруди і чи завжди ті відповідають
нормам І які плани на цей рік стосовно
цього
ви знаєте Дуже гарне запитання адже на
сьогодні ми маємо дещо коливання у
відсотках у забезпеченні закладів освіти
захисними спорудами коли ми на 1 вересня
виходили 69% 15 вересня це вже було 72%.
десь на 1 жовтня ми вже мали 76%, але
наші збройні сили мають великі успіхи на
фронті ми Део купували значну кількість
території і тому Кількість шкіл і
закладів освіти на сьогодні збільшилась
які в напідконтрольній Україні території
тим самим відсоток укриттів дещо
знизився Але разом щорі що тижнева буває
в певних областях Працюємо з гологом
військових адміністрацій з керівниками
місцевих громад і тому підвищуємо якось
безпеки наших учнів на сьогодні на 15-17
лютого ми будемо мати оновлену
статистику по укриттях І звісно теж є
одразу опублікуємо на сьогодні в
середньому в середньому 71 трошки більше
ніж 71% закладів загальної середньої
освіти тобто шкіл це
9623 школи мають укриття як і атестовані
державною службою надзвичайних ситуацій
спеціальними комісіями
місцевих органів по закладах дошкільної
освіти в нас Майже
53%, А найбільше забезпечена
профтехосвіта оскільки там мають
відбуватися заняття виключно в очному
форматі для набуття професійних навичок
і в цьому контексті
забезпечені закладів профтеху освіти
складає 94% укриттів заклади фахової
речі та вищої освіти це майже 90% в
цьому контексті маємо абсолютно
прозору
стратегію держави щодо забезпечення
якості освіти формування максимально
влучного або змішаному форматі в
державному бюджеті на 23-й рік ми маємо
спеціальну субвенцію яка розрахована на
створення укриттів для закладів
загальної середньої освіти це півтора
мільярди гривень ми маємо підтримку від
Європейського Союзу пані усуну фонд
виділили нам 100 мільйонів євро для
укриття для побудови укриття це там теж
Ми формуємо певну стратегію для опорних
шкіл для філії опорних шкіл в Наш фонд
Східна Європа партнер великий нам дав
можливість обладнати 28 укриттів У
деяких регіонах України це Київ Вінниця
Чернігів Суми Хмельницькі Одеса отримали
цю допомогу наш безпосередній партнер
теж в повному обсязі більше ніж тисяча
шкіл була обла- укриттів була обладнана
в школах
Я вас дуже добре розумію на жаль не не
безкінечний ефірний час Я дуже
перепрошую але ми почули що ситуація з
закриттям в принципі понад 90% в
середньому забезпечення п міністрів Дуже
дякую за ваш час і за вашу роботу це
Сергій шкарлет міністр освіти та науки
України бо в нас на зв'язку дякую